how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have our very first look at
Jared Leto as Morbius the living vampire
this photo was leaked right before we
are supposed to get the official trailer
for Morbius from Sony which we
reportedly know the exact date and time
but let's talk about how Jared Leto is
completely unrecognizable in this photo
as you can see here Sony has done an
amazing job with this this is actually
the first time that we've ever actually
seen Jared Leto as Morbius as Sony and
the rest of the cast and crew have done
a pretty good job at keeping everything
under wraps but this photo is very
impressive it seems to be a combination
of makeup work really good makeup work
and CGI and typically I'd be a little
bit worried about CGI but Sony did a
really good job with venom I had no
problems with the way anything looked in
venom and I think this is going to be
less CGI than that so a good combination
of makeup artists and CGI are going to
do the trick here and as you can see
here this is taken directly from the
Waggoner 90s comics this is practically
a perfect replica of this comic photo
right here and how Morbius looks in the
comics so this is a great sign for the
movie and apparently there's going to be
a lot of characters that look really
really good according to producer Avi
Arad IV said wait until you see the way
he looks what we have done with this
character you will love it there are so
many other great characters on the way
too you will see we're just getting
started so if this is a pretty good
indication on what we can expect to see
from Sony's Morbius the living vampire
it looks pretty good now what are the
really cool things about Morbius coming
out is that it's said to be in the same
universe as venom Sony is kind of making
their own cinematic universe out of kind
of b-list characters I don't think that
anybody would really call venom a b-list
character but they're taking characters
like venom Morbius Kraven the hunter and
they're putting them in their own
cinematic universe but they're giving
them grade-a actors and right now
there's rumors that venom could appear
in Morbius and there is a president for
that in the comics as they've come in
contact with each other many many times
plus if Sony truly is setting up their
own Cinematic Universe it would make
sense that we would see venom and not to
mention Spider Man Morbius and Spider
Man have a long history together in the
comics and recently
with the whole Marvel Sony deal we don't
really know what happened with
spider-man as far as contracts are
concerned in fact it has been confirmed
that Sony is speaking with Tom Holland
about a cameo in venom two if this
happens that would put spider-man in the
same universe with Sony's universe as
Morbius and that would open up the
future to a lot of possibilities but
we'll have to see how Morbius does on
its own first and speaking of it's been
reported that we know the exact date and
time of the trailer according to Daniel
RPK the trailer for Morbius is supposed
to come on Monday January 13th at 6 a.m.
Pacific time so if you're trying to
watch the trailer for Morbius right when
it comes out that is when it is
reportedly coming out and of course I'll
be doing a breakdown on it as soon as it
comes out as well and based off of this
photo I have pretty high hopes for it I
didn't know what to expect at first but
this photo looks really really good and
it looks just like it does in the comics
so so far looking good but again we'll
see the trailer on Monday so let me know
what you think about this photo do you
like it and would you eventually like
spider-man and venom and Kraven the
hunter and the others to be in their own
universe together and have their own
crossover film be sure to let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
also don't forget to give the video a
like if you enjoyed it and don't forget
to subscribe when notifications turned
on so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Marvel and the
Sony verse giveaway info for an xbox one
and a ps4 is in the description down
below and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof